alors madame durette wars vous êtes la
directrice principale de l'éducation
pour l'organisme qu est ce qu une
jeunesse quel était l'objectif principal
de votre programme que décret est éduqué
lors de ses débuts landes novembre 2010
cet objectif principal c'est de vraiment
introduira les éducatrices à l'aco d'âge
dans la salle de classe et aussi aux
stratégies de penser computationnelle
puis votre programme visant à mieux
outiller les jeunes à devenir les jeux
le site des créateurs plutôt que des
consommateurs de leur monde numérique
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par là
abc qu'on veut vraiment ce que c'est que
les enfants ont la chance de pouvoir
dans leur vie technologique alors d'être
un créateur au lieu d'un consommateur ça
veut dire que que vous utiliser les
technologies comme un outil pour vous et
votre propre outil au lieu d'être
vraiment est contrôlé par des
technologies et quels sont les défis en
matière de codage informatique dans les
si on prend les territoires du nord
canadien de l'arctique exactement à
baisser ça dépend vraiment de la
territoire évidemment que mais nunavut
où on était les mots dernière elle les
défis surtout l'absence de là sans fil
ont vraiment pas un réseau assez forte
pour faire la même chose que les
étudiants dans le sud pu faire
et dans les autres territoires ben jeudi
aidant que même il ya un iphone a vu
petit peu que mini économie qui petit
peu moins stable peut-être alors je ne
suis pas le genre du du travail qui peut
trouver peut-être avec les technologies
ça va être un petit peu moins puisqu'on
a vu dans le yukon
peut-être ils n'ont vraiment un vicky
qui ça bouge la wildrose oui on voit une
économie assez stable qui est commence
vraiment il ya un engouement pour le
codage c'est ce que vous avez remarqué
est ce que vous trouvez que
l'enseignement de l'informatique dans
les écoles est optimale en ce moment non
non mais premièrement on en a presque
les technologies plus qu'un main que
mais il nous est vraiment je sais
comprendre comment utiliser les
logiciels
le but de notre organisme c'est vraiment
de comprendre la programmation la
logique de la programmation et mieux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
technologies les réseaux y est
toute la vie digitale de l'enfant alors
ça commençait des troupes est bon mais
on voit que les ministères d'éducation
maintenant de plus en plus voit que les
partance de ça mais ça bouge lentement
lentement oui je vous insistez beaucoup
sur l'intégration donc du codage à
d'autres matières scolaires comment est
ce qu'on fait ça concrètement ben
exemple une langage qu'on utilise
souvent cs coach c'est le langage qui
est écrit à m haïti est situé matricide
technologie puisque c'est un langage qui
permetta les enfants de faire des
animations alors il peut faire des
animations que faire des jeux de vidyo
il peut faire des choses peuvent faire
des gens des choses qu'ils utilisent
à la maison la vie quotidienne dans la
vie quotidienne alors comme ça on peut
faire ça d'erding classe d'art on peut
aussi utiliser une chose qu'on a fui
dans un corps créé éduquer c'est qu'on a
on a donné 90 micro bits sur des petites
ordinateur est très très petit que les
enfants plus programmé avec une
excellente m
pour faire grimper de m ok à la répudie
lisez ça dans leurs classes d'éducation
physique pour stimuler les activités
hockey puis là disons qu'elle serait ça
fait 18 mois que vous vous orchestré ces
programmes qu'ils seraient vos attentes
pour la suite de ce programme cots
décret éduquer nos étangs c'est de
vraiment travailler beaucoup plus avec
les ministères d'indication les
ministères d'animation à les niveaux
province provincial oui pour vraiment
vraiment rendre ça dans les dents les
écoles dans tout les écoles puis on
attend aussi on espère que le
gouvernement fédéral va continuer cette
initiative ça va prendre beaucoup plus
que 18 mois pour enseigner la codage à
tous les enfants élus tous les
éducatrices dans canada donc ce sera à
surveiller pour les prochains mois oui
oui merci qui merci